[Music]
foreign
legs that turn that that that that that
that that turn uh uh blonde in the Sun
[Music]
Corn Pop was a bad dude
and he ran a bunch of bad boys
so I learned about kids jumping on my
lap and I've Loved kids jumping on my
lap
[Music]
grows the economy
what a stupid son of a
hello I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report we are live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals uh subscribe if you
have not it's July 12th in the year 2023
I do have to get a couple clerical
things out early first off I should warn
you everyone in my house
in my home my Homestead except for me is
puking their brains out right now uh
started with Justin last night
Luke is puking David is puking there's a
lot of puke my assistant Daphne who's
normally here she's puking uh you three
are not puking right we went through
this already nobody feels the puke could
happen at any time and I was told right
before we started the show that if
something happens to me if I suddenly in
the middle of the show if I start
feeling it that Connor has some sort of
graphic that he can throw to in case
there is an emergency but anyway I gotta
plow through the show today and then I
just got to help out it was it was I was
up all night it was it was a lot
everybody's gonna be okay we're getting
fluids in everybody and all that stuff
so it's going to be okay but a little
crazy around here and speaking of crazy
real quick little Twitter drama happened
this morning uh you know for the last
couple days I've been going pretty hard
after uh the view Harpy Anna Navarro in
on yesterday's show I officially
announced that she's the worst of all of
the hosts and I think I laid out a
fairly strong case I know many people I
I saw the comments and I checked on
locals a lot of people still think that
Sunny Hosten is the worst because she's
just profoundly unlikable she he's
condescending there's just nothing
there's not even a nugget of
pleasantness within her where maybe you
could argue there is something with Aunt
Anna my argument was more so that
because Anna lives here and uh excuse me
oh man it could have happened right
there because Anna who lives here in
Florida and she's so rabidly against it
and lying that she just to me she takes
the cake on this but I I get it's
somewhat subjective everyone can have
their own opinion on that anyway then
yesterday uh I was driving and I saw
this bumper sticker check this out I saw
this car a Kia with a couple bumper
stickers here Trump 20 to 24 years in
prison Biden Harris don't DeSantis my
democracy whatever that means another
Biden Harris OMG GOP WTF so I took a
picture of that uh and I uh tweeted it
at Anna Navarro and I said I think that
Anna Navarro is driving in front of me
with a couple silly faces well Anna
Navarro responded this morning
and in only a way that a rich elitist
leftist could
I drive a Maserati boo a Maserati which
costs around two hundred thousand
dollars now I don't begrudge anyone
spending their own money on whatever
they want to but you know she pretends
she's this leftist era well she was a
fake conservative for a long time now I
think she's gone full-blown like crazy
Progressive lunatic uh but I did respond
do we have my response I think we do I
think I nailed this one hey nobody said
being a leftist hack doesn't pay well
so that's how my morning's going puking
all over me both on Twitter and in real
life uh but we do have a big show for
you and we're doing a Community Q a we
moved it we usually do them on Thursdays
we are doing it uh today because of how
crazy the morning was I needed to do
something just sort of a little bit
condensed instead of a full narrative
show but I do want to show you just a
couple clips of a really interesting
interview uh you know Tucker Carlson
seems to be sort of getting out there
again right he's releasing his show once
every week or two weeks on Twitter right
now we'll see what comes of that uh he's
been doing a few more interviews he
obviously was interviewed by Russell
Brand in the UK last week and just in
the last couple days uh he made it to
Romania and you know that the most
famous Romanian prisoner under house
arrest uh is Andrew Tate and they sat
down for an interview and there's a
couple clips that I think are just like
deeply connected to things that we've
been talking about here uh first Tucker
asked Andrew Tate and of course you guys
you know kickboxer Andrew Tate and he's
sort of become a hero of the men's
Rights Movement he's very controversial
for a series of reasons
um whatever controversial what does it
mean some people like it some people
don't that's how they feel about me it's
probably how some people feel about you
anyway Tucker asked Andrew what it is
about his message what it is about the
things that he's saying that's driving
so many people crazy
so what is it about your message do you
think that infuriates certain people
well my message traditional my message
is traditional masculinity my message is
to stand up and say what you mean and
mean what you say and even going to the
gym nowadays is an act of defiance
because when you have a man who's built
with any degree of principle you say no
to things and I think if I have to
analyze my message and why I'm so
disliked by the people who dislike me
it's not the things I'm saying it's the
fact that if you adhere to my principles
and you adhere to the things I say you
end up being the kind of person who will
resist certain ideas you say no what
kind of man never says no name a man who
never says no
men say no right men men wake up and say
no I don't think that should be done
this way no my children will not be
taught that no father's primary job
absolutely So when you say to men listen
you're allowed to have an opinion you're
allowed to have standards you're allowed
to have boundaries and barriers you're
allowed to get up and become important
and work hard and try hard and become
the kind of man who can't be controlled
then you're seen as an enemy and I
especially with the massive influence
I've gained
I think they look at me and go ah he's
helping men resist to slave programming
we don't need him around we need to
empty their brains so we can inject the
slave programming and convince men to be
eunuchs because once you're eunuched
then you're not a threat
I think I buy that because your message
I I'm not the world's expert on your
message but I've seen a lot of it and
it's not explicitly political actually
no it's not political at all yeah Tucker
kind of sums up my feelings on that like
I've watched a bunch of clips of Andrew
Tate and we've shown a bunch here I'm
not an expert in everything he's done or
everything he's been accused of or any
of those things but if we just take what
he said there for face value that that's
the thing that's driving his popularity
which is absolutely insane right now and
again the guy is under house arrest
trapped in Romania while he's doing this
interview and he's still not holding
back if you listen to some of the things
well masculinity that men should be men
uh yeah of course men should be men it's
part of the problem that we have right
now that men don't know if they're men
or if they're women women don't know if
they're women or their men all of this
odd gender confusion that you should say
what you mean I mean I don't know that
there's anything that I could agree with
more on that like you must say what you
mean that's the that's the most
important thing you can do as a human in
some way because the second you don't do
that you are actually just giving energy
you're giving air oxygen
to the machine that is coming for you in
every which way right so all and all of
us do it to some degree I I don't do it
that much anymore but I basically say
whatever I think right like I actually
can't think of anything off the top of
my head that I'm thinking about that I
don't say on this show uh but we've all
done it to in different ways in our life
we maybe do it in our marriage or we do
it with friends or or we do it uh over
at you know work over politics or
whatever but say what you mean like
that's important go to the gym we showed
you the the headline yesterday what was
that was that in salon nose axios who
the hell had that freaking stupid
headline about working out yesterday
MSNBC I mean they're all the same
basically at this point uh about you
know how Fitness is now a tool of the
far right and we talked about it it's
like because if you take care of
yourself if you stand up straight with
your shoulders back Jordan Peterson if
you are not eating bugs and gruel and
growing fat and only playing video
against and watching porn if you're
doing other things with your life that
give you value and purpose you're less
dependent on the system and that's not
what the system is interested in say no
oh right say no enough is enough I can
directly link that one to what's been
going on here in Florida right what what
lit DeSantis on fire it was enough is
enough we are not going to let you talk
to our kids about gender identity we're
not going to allow this neo-racism in
the school say no and then enough people
will start backing you one way or
another whether you're a politician or
if a private person or anything else
resist certain ideas I mean that one's
deeply connected to that right you don't
have to say yes to everything you are
allowed to have some standards as Tate
said you're allowed to have some set of
beliefs
he said standards you can have opinions
uh and and that will make it so that you
cannot be controlled and doesn't that
seem what it all boils down to these
days they want us to be controlled eat
this go out and we tell you put this on
your face get injected with this we're
going to take this amount of money from
you because you're this type of person
we're gonna let you into this school
because you're that type of person
resist the thing guys we can do it and
more and more people are waking up I
want to show you one other clip of uh
Tate and Tucker because they started
talking about the war the war non-war in
Russia Ukraine take a look
why do you think
um support for the war in Ukraine
support for Ukraine side in the war
against Russia support for a war against
Russia in the West
is kind of the the bottom line issue for
the people who run the US government and
for the American Media why I mean I
guess you could argue about it but there
isn't an argument about it in the United
States there's a position in anyone who
doesn't hold it is attacked and punished
why why is that so important well the
first thing I think we should all do is
I think we should all give Putin credit
for curing covet
right
because when his invasion happened copen
went away
I thought about that think about it it's
almost to the day
so we have to give him some credit at
least for doing that like maybe the bad
guy of the world but at least he could
covert for everybody nearly instantly
Fair thank you for thank you President
Putin
um yeah I up until this point never
really commented too heavily on politics
yes but I understand very well I like to
believe what's happening with Ukraine
and Russia
and what I will say to the people who
are watching this at home is that if you
are
naive enough to believe that there are
good guys and bad guys in wars and it's
as simple as good and bad and that the
bad guys are crazy and the good guys
want freedom they need to do a little
bit more investigation into what's
really happening and when you look at
the vested interest of any country or
any person can I just ask you to pause
and just comment that's the truest thing
what you just said that is that and
anyone who doesn't understand that
should shut the up and I mean it
all right you don't hear Tucker drop the
F-bomb too often I I have to say I don't
totally agree with the premise but I
agree with sort of the the Blue Sky
version of what he said the blue sky
version of what he said is that is what
he's trying to say is that war is very
complex it's not always just like oh
those are the obvious bad guys and we're
always the obvious good guys right like
it's just not like that like if you were
to look at say the Iraq War like Saddam
certainly was a bad guy and he did awful
things to his people and he did awful
things to the Kurds and everyone else he
was definitely a bad guy but us going to
war at a country to a country that did
nothing against us like we were trying
to maybe we were you know somewhere the
argument was we were trying to free the
people we were trying to bring democracy
okay the road tells paid with good
intentions we also killed about 400 000
people in that case there's a lot of bad
guys to go around but but in like the
most like specific level I don't think
that there's no situation where there
are good guys and bad guys when it comes
to war or when it comes to conflict and
I and I think
perhaps had they discussed it a little
bit further I think that they would
agree with that I mean Tucker knows uh
that if in his community let's say uh he
lives in a nice Community wherever that
might be a bunch of people there and
they're all Pleasant and they're nice
and safe with each other uh if a bunch
of marauders came a bunch of Vigilantes
came and started attacking people and
raping the women and pillaging and all
those things you could declare war on
them and that would be very just a war
is just when it's to defend your
property and your family and things of
that nature so I think a little bit of
the subjectiveness of good guys and bad
guys is probably they probably just kind
of glossed over it a little bit but I
think the broader point he meant related
to Russia and Ukraine is it's not just
as simple as Putin is just purely the
bad guy and zelenski and now the United
States which is running the proxy war
are we're just the good guys we're just
the good guys right now like there's an
awful lot of people and weapons
manufacturers and everybody else getting
really rich on this right so it's not
just as simple as is that I think was
the overriding point but but a bunch of
things happened yesterday related to the
war not war in Ukraine I got some info
from the daily wire world leaders are
meeting in Lithuania for NATO's annual
Summit to discuss a range of issues
including whether or not Ukraine should
be allowed into the group Monday evening
the NATO Secretary General said I am
absolutely certain that we will have
unity and a strong message on Ukraine
however Tuesday Morning Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski slammed
NATO for not moving faster to welcome
his country into the alliance and for
setting no clear timeline as to when it
will be allowed in zelenski has been
banging the World War III drum for
months now Ukraine entered enter
entering NATO would undoubtedly result
in direct conflict between the west and
Russia at the same time the Biden
Administration has made it clear that it
is no interest in peace the longer this
war goes on the more people will die
meanwhile the United States is running
low on ammunition according to our own
Commander in Chief instead of crafting
an off-ramp NATO the US and Ukraine are
looking to prolong the war so before I
get to a quick video from zelenski
himself the basics of what you need to
understand there is that NATO and NATO
countries have this agreement if one
NATO country is attacked then everyone
in in unison must attack back right
that's how it is if Russia was to attack
say Germany which is a NATO country then
everybody in NATO has to get in on that
so by adding Ukraine to Nato and by the
way many years ago after the fall of
Soviet Union uh Ukraine gave up their
nuclear Armament they gave up their
nukes so that they wouldn't have to in
exchange they got sort of protections
from Russia it was a mistake right but
okay that's be that as it may
the problem with having Ukraine
regardless of where you fall in the war
right now the problem with having
Ukraine just get into NATO right now is
that means it would basically instigate
World War III on day one everyone would
have to get in on this war what's also
interesting about it is Biden just keeps
saying we're going to endlessly uh give
you weapons you have no need to come to
the table and that's what zielinski
keeps saying we're so we're being told
on one hand all of these ukrainians are
dying it's horrible there's been mass
destruction and some degree of that is
true but generally wouldn't you then be
like okay let's talk about a settlement
let's see are there some concessions we
can make to Putin even if he's a really
bad dude and this was totally unjust and
you can't go off your borders to attack
another country and all that but none of
that seems to be happening uh here's
zelenski himself yesterday at the NATO
Summit calling for more weapons the NATO
membership and a bunch more
I think for today three priority
questions the first one is
weapon packages new weapon packages for
supporting our army on the battlefield
and that is one the second I think the
invitation to Nita and
um
we want to be
on the same page with everybody with all
their understanding and for today what
we what we what we hear and understand
that we'll have this invitation when
security measures
will allow all right apologies for the
audio on that it was extremely low the
actual audio on the mic so we had to
bump it up so that's why there was some
crackling there so he wants more weapons
and he wants in on NATO so he wants to
extend the war and let's even giving him
the complete benefit of the doubt let's
just say this guy just wants to defend
his country there's nothing nefarious
going on there's no money laundering
there it has nothing to do with Biden
and the laptop and all of the stuff
let's just pretend all this is all on
the all on the up and up right it's like
does that mean we still have to give
this guy endless weapons and also enter
an international agreement that will
immediately drag us into World War III
and why is it that as Tucker pointed out
there's really just no voices in America
in Corporate America in mainstream
America that are giving a little pause
to this thing yeah I can talk about it a
little bit that way Tucker could and now
he's no longer on mainstream media uh
guys like Glenn Greenwald David sack
there are some people talking about it
but we certainly should at least be able
to talk about it but every time anyone
says that and I have no doubt the Media
Matters people or whoever that watch
this show they're waiting for me to say
something so they can see see you see
Reuben is a Russian stooge he loves that
Putin he loves Putin just because I'm
asking questions and I don't want to be
driven to World War III by the way to go
to war we need Congressional
authorization I know we don't do that
anymore right so when when Obama went to
war in Libya when we got rid of Gaddafi
and now Libya is a complete failed State
we didn't actually go to war he didn't
get Congressional authorization he
called it a kinetic military action
sounds like Xbox Connect but it was a
kinetic military action so they always
find ways we can drop bombs all over the
place but I think at some point if
you're endlessly funding a war if you're
giving guys billions of dollars to kill
other people at some point you're at War
anyway our secretary of state Anthony
blinken went on television yesterday and
uh he welcomed Sweden and Finland into
NATO so that is one thing that happened
in the last couple days uh and he tells
Putin and you ain't gonna win this thing
man
let's start we know Sweden is now
following Finland and tornado what
message do you think that this will send
to Russia or what message do you want it
to send if any
well it sends two messages first of all
our alliance is stronger it's bigger
with two new members Finland and now
Sweden uh and it's more united than ever
and in terms of Russia's aggression
against Ukraine it's sending a very
strong message to Putin that he's not
going to outlast us he's not going to
outlast you I mean it's just meaningless
dribble like that okay I have no
inherent problem with Sweden and Finland
getting in NATO but do you think Sweden
and Finland do you think Putin woke up
this morning like uh oh oh Sweden and
Finland are in the NATO what am I going
to do get me some vodka so I can think
about this like he's been at war in
essence with the United States and
Ukraine you think it's gonna the thing
that's gonna turn the war around or a
bunch of Finnish soldiers on the border
of Russia like it's just this is what we
do with everything it like all sounds
good blinking it sounds good we'll have
a bigger broader Coalition except nobody
does anything everyone does jack
except for the United States that's how
it works so if we don't do anything
nothing happens and if we do do
something something happens good or bad
that's how it is anyway there is one
world leader uh who is at NATO right now
who is basically calling for peace he's
saying enough of funding this war can
everybody calm down let's respect
borders etc etc uh that's the guy that
everyone in the west seems to call the
fascist these days although he was voted
democratically and is extremely popular
within his own country I'm talking about
Victor Orban of Hungary and here he is
calling for peace
as it's real news
okay so there's obviously way more than
that but the point is he's one of the
few voices in the world on the
international stage who's just saying
how about we just don't endlessly fund
this why is it that all these Western
nations want to endlessly fund
Ukraine fighting Russia whether they
think they're fighting back whether they
think it's partially Justified fully
Justified or whatever and as I often say
at the end of the day we can arm this
guy with all of the Munitions we want we
can give them all of the f-15s we can
give them the cluster bombs and the
whole freaking thing the mother of all
Bombs all of the stuff and at the end of
the day he still has nukes so the idea
that we're going to defeat this guy
militarily that one day we're all going
to wake up and they're going to be like
it happened we defeated Russia
militarily we've taken over and by the
way then what happens post Putin
probably gets worse but it's just a
crazy notion so there's one guy who's
doing it I happen to meet that one guy
this is at the prime minister's Palace
in Hungary that's right on the Danube
River over there and we chatted for
about 10 minutes you guys know this is
during our trip about two months ago and
it was really interesting I this was you
know just the two of us chatting for
about 10 minutes or so and all he said
to me repeatedly repeatedly
was I love my country I want to protect
my country I don't think we have to have
these adventurous Wars all over the
place I want to protect my borders and
the people of my country he just
repeated that over and over he had a big
smile on his face
that's it that's it and I think that we
should be thinking a little bit more
like that within our own borders uh I
know that puts me outside of the
mainstream it actually puts me closer to
say tucker and RFK who by the way RFK Jr
I did interview on Sunday part one is up
right now full thing is up on locals and
some other Clips will be coming out uh
throughout the week and I will now get
to the Ruben before Community Q a where
the first question happens to be about
RFK Jr uh prusky says is what RFK Junior
uh is saying if what RFK junior is
saying is true when you had the
interview with him about Russia wanting
to do a peace deal why is the United
States preventing it wouldn't that be
treason in a sense well there's
something very interesting there so if
you didn't see at least part one of the
interview he talks about that that
Russia has repeatedly gone for a peace
deal by the way former Israeli Prime
Minister naftali Bennett from like a
year and a half ago before Netanyahu
took over he went uh he went to Ukraine
I think he went to Ukraine and to Russia
he must have went to Russia and meet
with Putin and they basically had a
peace deal worked out in the United
States and Ukraine said no to it that
was a year and a half ago so rfk's
argument is that Russia actually does
want a deal but the West is just pushing
and pushing and pushing and if you
eventually push the guy with nukes again
into a corner what is that guy going to
do so is it treason I mean I would leave
that for like the the Constitutional
lawyers to figure out but I think it at
the very least it makes you hearken back
to that clip of Andrew Tate and Tucker
Carlson like the good guy bad guy thing
here is not that clear
it's not that clear I am not saying
Putin is a good guy he invaded a
Sovereign Nation you cannot do that if
you want to be in in the the community
of Nations right you can't just go into
someone else's territory and start
taking over now we can talk about ethnic
Russians and all of those things and how
the Soviet Union was broken up and okay
all of that fine but I'm not saying
Putin is a great guy but I don't think
zelenski is a great guy either and he's
getting awfully rich and awfully famous
and there's an awful lot of money being
poured through that country right now
and I think it's at least worth thinking
about Joe says was there anything in the
RFK interview that surprised you from
either a personal or political point of
view
well I don't know that this surprised me
exactly but but we opened with the first
question I said hey right off the top
um I was a Democrat I can no longer call
myself a Democrat anymore what makes you
still a Democrat and actually I thought
it was his only sort of somewhat muddled
answer throughout you know he hearkens
back to the history of his family and I
think that's respectable this was
similar to our affirmative action
question which by the end he sort of
agreed that it was not a great comment
when he said that it was a bad decision
by the Supreme Court he he really was
like he fully understood the other
argument but I think I think he's so
connected I don't mean this as a
judgment call really I think he's so
connected to the Kennedy Legacy and who
his uncle and his father were and his
other Uncle what that name means and
what that was in that party that I think
he's having a little trouble
disconnecting from that but I think by
the time this thing is done by the time
the DNC is done with him by the time
more and more Republicans who happen to
disagree with I mean I disagree with him
on affirmative action I disagree with
him on policies around climate change we
didn't unfortunately we didn't have time
to really get into that
um I I'm sure I disagree with him on
some abortion stuff like there's plenty
of stuff there and we get into a bunch
of it but he will always find the door
it will be exactly where I was seven
years ago the door will always be open
for people on the right to talk to you
about those things and there's broad
agreement when it comes to covid when it
comes to Ukraine Etc
so I think he's just sort of he's in the
mix of that thing but what I was very
impressed by uh he was happy to have the
conversation he said he'd be more than
happy to have it again I asked him a
little bit about what he thought you
know I said well people know what you
think about Trump they know what you
think about Biden what do you think
about DeSantis he had a lot of good
things to say about Santa said he'd be
happy to talk to him so like that we do
need more of that and I think that
that's the the main piece that was my
takeaway cool mom says if mind reading
happens during our lifetime I'm going
Balls to the walls and filling my head
with as much truth as possible I'm also
going to say countless prayers your
thoughts
why not why not well first off if mind
reading is possible you know to some
extent mind reading is possible already
not the way we traditionally think of
mind reading like someone could just
like walk up to you and like go like
this and like know what's in your mind
but mind reading the way the algorithms
work the way that you know our click
habits are know more about us in a way
than we do like we could say oh I like
these things but then you can the
algorithms and big Tech can look at your
click behaviors and go actually those
aren't the things you like you do like
all of that violence you do like all of
the Mayhem you do like this that the
other thing so in some ways there's a
there's a technological mind reading
that is happening already but if they uh
if they get to mind read us yeah I would
fill your head up with as much truth as
possible if prayer helps you get there
then God bless you uh Nick says you did
a great job of a fair interview with RFK
Jr despite your declared vote for
DeSantis if he doesn't win the
Democratic primary would you support him
being the VP pick for a republic
presidential ticket
um this has come up repeatedly I've
discussed it a little bit with my guys
on the inside look there's a lot of good
there so without fully repeating what I
just said there's good on the covid
stuff there's good on the Ukraine stuff
the the affirmative action thing like to
me that's such a big one
that that could be a big that could be a
big deal breaker but again he did not
hold his position position strong and if
anything he kind of agreed with me at
the end but but you'll see more on that
one and that's by the way to his credit
again I'm not going after him for that
saying that he was mealy-mouthed with it
it's his credit that he said this is
what I believe he links it back to
Growing Up in Jim Crow South and a bunch
of things that aren't necessarily about
what's going on today
but okay uh there's that I think the
abortion thing's probably a bit much
because I'm guess I should have asked we
didn't get into it unfortunately but I
should have asked if he was okay with
Roe v Wade being flipped which I'm
guessing he wasn't
um I think there's a spot for him ah
let's do it this way I think the best
position for him wouldn't necessarily be
VP I think the next the best position
for him is you get to Santa says
president now we have what is the
mission the mission is to reform the
agencies is to get wokeness out of the
government to go after pharmaceutical
companies he's a lawyer who's been going
after pharmaceutical companies for like
40 years you put him at as the head of
that I don't know what that department
is necessarily attorney general perhaps
something like that I don't necessarily
think vice president where he's the
heartbeat away from the presidency is
the right idea
um if if you hold more conservative
beliefs but I think there is absolutely
some role for him there gamma says Dave
after her emotional monologue on Father
and Son Joe and Hunter's unconditional
love will Anna Navarro emote on
robinette's inappropriate yet
unconditional father and daughter love
for his daughter Ashley wait a minute
I'm confused about this does anyone know
what this is about this one's going
completely over my head you see we don't
always check these beforehand I try to
do them on the Fly
that's an emotional I don't know father
it's not unconditional love will Annette
of our emote on robinette's
inappropriate who's Robinette can you
Google Robinette we're going to come
back to this one
Robinette emotional father and daughter
love for their daughter Ashley wow you
stumped everybody gamma I'm gonna send
you a little sign something because you
stumped
Robinette is Joe Biden
oh the Ashley's diary she refers to Joe
as Robinette
yeah all right we're gonna do a little
digging on this one but gamma because
you stumped us all on the Fly and as I
said I try not to every now and again I
take a quick glance at the questions but
I try not to read them in advance
because I want to do this as much off
the top of my head and be as honest as
possible uh you got us and I'm gonna
send you something Brock's got some info
Robinette is Jill Biden okay let me try
this one more time bear with us what
Robin
ette Robinette
is Joe Biden's middle name is Robinette
all right I'm being told on the Fly
people that Joe Biden's middle name is
Robinette so now I'm going to read this
again Dave after her emotional monologue
on Father and Son Joe and Hunter's
unconditional love will Anna Navarro
emote on robinette's inappropriate yet
unconditional father and daughter love
for his daughter Ashley
but isn't Ashley Joe Biden's
granddaughter
yes for Hunter Biden's daughter oh for
Hunter Biden's daughter Ashley
we're gonna chew on this one for a bit
and but you I see there's something
there's something there you've made us
all think I thank you we're going to
send you a little signed book plate or
something forget me on the Fly okay
Casey says uh why is AI so important
humankind has made so many advances
without it do you think we need it to
keep making discoveries look this is the
great challenge of our time really AI
the idea that we are we are so on the
verge and perhaps have already crossed
The Uncanny Valley when we will not know
what is real we will not know what is
manipulated I talked about the
algorithms before and how through Data
Mining and everything else they know
more about you than you know about
yourself right and the constant
surveillance and I said it the other day
you know you're in your living room
talking about how oh boy you know we the
carpet's Pretty Dirty we could use a a
new rug or something and then suddenly
you open up Instagram and there's ads
for carpets and rugs like there's so
many weird things there but AI the idea
that all of this information can be
sorted so incredibly quickly and you
could just go into a chat and be given
the truth even though we know that chat
GPT for example has been highly biased
and of course which way does the bias go
always to the left the big thing when
chat gbt sort of first debuted what two
months ago was that chat GPT if you
asked it to write a nice poem about Joe
Biden could write you this long
Soliloquy about how lovely Joe Biden is
but if you asked it to write a pleasant
poem about Donald Trump it said it was
unable to so human biases have already
leaked into the AI then beyond just text
AI there's all of the deep fake stuff
that within within years I mean you can
basically do it already I've seen some
crazy videos on this of Tom Cruise I've
seen Joe Biden ones a whole bunch of
others they'll be able to fake it you
will watch videos and not know that it
is not the person you think it is and
just what would it be like when a video
goes viral of Joe Biden announcing that
we're dropping a nuke on Russia or
whatever it might be or God knows what
they could do with that related to porn
related to to virtually everything and
also our need for humans to do things
will will constantly be decreasing
because we will be replaced by fake
humans there might be some positives to
that maybe it will give us more free
time to go do things that will give us
purpose but most likely it'll just give
us more free time uh to play video games
and and waste time and all of those
other things so humans made it many many
thousands of years and western
civilization made it a couple thousand
years uh without AI
um are there reasons that maybe we would
need AI to do interplanetary travel
right to have a sentient being I mean if
you watch watch any of the great Sci-Fi
movies of all time uh watch 2001 like
the idea that a computer would be able
to manage most of the functions of a
ship that was going into deep space so
that we could keep humans in cryostasis
because they wouldn't survive the long
trip watch Interstellar like is there a
reason for some of this stuff of course
of course I actually had a chapter in
pomper in this country about all of this
about all of the big technological
questions that we're gonna have to face
and then we realized at the end that it
was like it didn't quite fit maybe you
know know maybe we'll do something with
that maybe we'll do something with that
I'll get back on that one uh Margot says
hey Dave here's a different type of
question what are your thoughts on the
seven wonders of the world and any idea
why the Great Pyramid is not considered
one of the seven so the seven we we
listed them out for you uh the seven are
the Coliseum which is in Rome Italy the
Great Wall of China the Taj Mahal in
India Christ the Redeemer of course in
Brazil Machu Picchu in Peru Chichen Itza
in Mexico and Petra Jordan leave that up
for just a second so out of all of those
the only one actually that I've been to
is the Coliseum in Rome I was in Italy
in I've only been to Italy once which is
a damn shame we've really got to get
back in 1997 I was in Italy and did that
and actually that same year on on a trip
just a few months earlier I was in Egypt
and did go to the pyramids which as you
point out are not noted as one of the
Seven Wonders of the World which is
quite bizarre
um I would love to see the Great Wall
I'd love to see that yeah the Taj Mahal
Christ the Redeemer all of these things
are really amazing what was the question
though was the question have I been to
all of them oh why is the pyramids not
considered one of the seven I I don't
know I actually yeah there are pictures
of all of them right there do you do we
have it it's one of the ancient wonders
of the world it's not anymore oh
interesting it's considered one of the
ancient wonders of the world and I guess
these are all newer right so Taj Mahal
would be at least somewhat newer um yeah
I guess that does make right well the
Coliseum in Rome but that's Coliseum in
Rome is what a thousand years old
ah interesting very interesting people
see you learn a little bit I can even
learn on the fly on this program I would
like to get to all of those maybe we'll
do a trip to the seven wonders of the
world and we'll end it in the uh what
what do you call it the triangle the
Triangle Bermuda Triangle and then we'll
just dip out like that'll be that Sarah
says hey Dave I was wondering what do
you look at when you were filming do you
look directly into the camera or do you
have a mark of some sort I feel like if
I were to do what you do I would have a
hard time not looking at the other
people in the room how do you do it you
know what can we do something right now
Brock can you come around here and I
want you to can you take a picture from
behind me and we're going to show that
when we're going to post it in local so
people can actually see but what I'm
looking at right now when I'm pointing
right now directly to the camera so I am
looking at the camera but we have a
teleprompter that's Brock nice
sweatshirt Brock where'd you get that
from the closet the closet no a Ruben
dot store the closet the closet Real
Genius you're a marketing that's my
marketing guy marketing wizard over
there uh so he's gonna post that at
reubenreport.locals.com right now so you
guys can sort of see what I'm looking at
but in essence the screen that we have
because they they do something with a
mirror it's actually pretty cool so
Phoenix has the teleprompter so that's
how I'm able to read the questions but
keep looking at you the entire time
because it basically I can look at the
camera and it just sort of goes through
it the camera's going through the screen
and I can look this way so it's sort of
like a I guess it's a double-sided
mirror so to speak something like that
um well not double-sided mirror because
I'm not seeing myself I do see myself
when I sometimes I look down like that
that's where I see the clips that
Connor's throwing me I've got Connor to
my right and he's doing all the uh the
live videos that we're throwing to the
sound effects all that sort of stuff
Phoenix is running the prompter giving
me extra information if I need it Brock
sits next to him and he's just Googling
and doing social media while we're doing
it fact checking me on some things uh
sometimes Daphne's also in here she's
not in here today because she's puking
her brain's out just like my boys and
David are
is what it is
um and I could note that we just met
with the uh the contractor this week and
the uh the new Reuben report studio is
in the works it took us a little bit
longer than anticipated but it's all in
the works people uh stay tuned on that
uh Chad says what are you most excited
about for this upcoming Off the Grid
August
um well you know we didn't do an
off-grid August last year basically
because Justin was born on the sixth he
was supposed to he was due on the 22nd
ended up being born on the sixth and
then obviously family phone calls
Doctors Hospital blah blah blah it was
just like not gonna happen I tried to
basically stay off the news which I was
able to do for when I came back but in
terms of like not really being on this
thing and everything else that that
didn't work out that way
um we are taking a little trip without
the boys which we have not done
um since they've been born so we are
going to get away for a little bit so
that will be nice I know it's going to
be kind of tough you know we're we're
pretty tight-knit group here and like
spending some time away is going to be a
little bit I think it'll be probably
more difficult for David than me because
he's you know he's down there every day
with them all the time like really just
doing a truly incredible job like truly
truly
um where I'm often busy and here so my
separation is a bit more
um so I would say getting away a little
bit and uh
no no that's it it's just get it's just
get well you know what something else
this year too maybe a little bit more
than another years
um you know I haven't done that much
racehorse politics in the last like two
weeks on the show right like we haven't
done that much about the Santa said this
Trump said this but and I think getting
away from a little bit of that before
the debate so as you know I'm coming
back a little bit early this year I'm
going to come back on August 23rd in
Milwaukee Rumble is the exclusive live
streamer no YouTube Rumble only of the
of the Republican debate so it'll be on
Fox on television and then Rumble online
we're figuring out what what I'm going
to do that day but I think I'll be
anchoring rumble's coverage and
hopefully we get a whole bunch of big
people in some of the presidential
candidates and everything else but it'll
be pretty cool to have missed three
weeks you know three plus weeks
basically and then go right into that
and like feel that freshness and all of
it just conversed forth right back into
my face and we shall see how it goes uh
Jonathan says what's your daily or
weekly exercise and diet routine uh well
I'm on a nice kick right now in the gym
uh so you know we start our morning I've
told you this guy's I've told you guys
this before I take over for the uh for
the kids around 7 30 a.m at that point
I'm usually doing a little back and
forth with Phoenix on how we're laying
out the show but we're doing that over
text I take the boys we sit we roll
around we play We like I like wooden
toys as I've told you guys I don't like
electronic and plastic toys I don't like
all the beeps and everything so we've
got a lot of wood stuff that's my kind
of thing we like cups and uh you know
little things you can like that just
simple I like simple stuff which they're
really into
um do that in the morning David gets up
a little bit later we try to take a walk
every morning with Clyde it's important
to get Clyde out because he's got a
crazy amount of energy and if we don't
get that energy out it could be tough
throughout the day uh we do that and
then usually I have about an hour
that hopefully I can get into the gym we
have a separate structure at the house
that we turned into a gym and I get in
there I try to do like half hour of
cardio and then lift a little bit I'm
really trying to eat right now too I'm
just trying to like get in order for uh
for August going away being on the beach
and you know like I'm basically in good
shape but everybody could always lose
five pounds tighten up a little bit
um so I'm pretty much staying off sugars
and and carbs I'm just doing eggs in the
morning usually eggs or I do Greek
yogurt with a little bit of a little bit
of fruit I got like a strawberry
raspberry blueberry mix sometimes a
little honey on there for lunch
David we buy lunch for my team but I was
like I can't just keep doing like the
takeout thing all the time and These
Guys these guys they freaking love the
Chick-fil-A every day with you guys with
the Chick-fil-A it's like there's a
limit to the sauce I get it there's a
lot of sauces so we basically David does
usually like chicken thighs uh maybe
some rice some spinach mixed in very
simple I put a little Sriracha on there
nice and simple and then for dinner I'm
doing most of the cooking these days
because he's uh he's taking care of the
kids so we just do like a nice like
grilled something so either grilled
chicken or grilled steak or fish we've
been we've been on a nice fish kick
lately just like I'm here in Florida so
they got everything you know grouper
mahi mahi we can get tuna steaks you get
red snapper yellow Snapper Cod like I
just try a different fish at night
simple vegetable on the side asparagus
we did brussels sprouts last night
broccoli although nobody ate in this
house last night because everybody was
puking except for me and uh and usually
just like some uh simple potatoes in the
in the airfryer so I just yeah and then
I don't really do dessert had a little
uh I had a quarter of a piece of dark
chocolate last night and then there you
go 47 years old you you can judge in
your own way uh Mike says Dave loves the
show and being with uh Dave love the
show and being with you from the jump
can you get your crack staff to put
together a video of all the cold opens
and closes so we can share with our back
crazy liberal friends please thanks
and you rock the hizzle for Rizzle
Dizzle peace and bacon grease
one of you wrote that didn't you who is
this guy you rock the dis bacon grease
um we should do something with the cold
opens and closes
Phoenix nodded immediately which means
it will be taken care of we will figure
out something maybe during August you
know we're gonna have a bunch of content
coming out during August one of one of
the things that we have to do I find it
very infuriating in a way but talking
about algorithms and information all
that stuff if we go completely dark
which we did for a couple August meaning
put up nothing on our channels
the algorithm completely kicks you out
and then you have to spend basically two
months getting back in meaning people
don't see your videos anymore you're not
recommended anymore your Revenue like I
accept that in August we're going to
make very little money like I build it
into my budget every year it is what it
is what ends up happening because we put
up at one time we put up no content in
August and now we put up less content in
August but we're trying to do a little
bit more is that our September revenue
and it starts being really crappy so it
ends up really shifting how the how the
whole company can operate so we're going
to do a little bit more this year just
to put up some stuff uh for you guys but
not not drug you over the head it's
going to be some interviews we did a
bunch of fun stuff when are we putting
up that uh the Gatorade thing
when's that going on
later this week did I mention this
already on the show the guys had me they
took a red Gatorade
they took a red Powerade and a red Prime
drink and this Prime is I guess what all
kids are drinking these days I've never
drank it before they put them in mugs
like this did not tell me which was
which and I had to do a taste test I'm
not going to tell you anything more but
Brock said this is what the kids like on
the computer machine and that's what
we're going to put out there so we'll do
some silly stuff like that Steven says
what were some memorable moments this
past Reuben report year for you this
past year
um
I mean I think the most if I was to well
I was going to say this past man the
year went by so freaking fast my book
came out over a year ago holy cow
um this past year my best memory
specifically
it's been good and it's been such a blur
and with the kids it's been it's been a
lot well I have to say you know the trip
to Israel and Hungary
um was so refreshing and pleasant and
nice and it was it was nice to travel it
was nice to take the team it was nice to
eat different foods see different ways
of life have a little down time at the
beach but then also I would you know
what actually really more than anything
else it was Jerusalem more than anything
else uh as incredible as Tel Aviv was as
incredible as Budapest was like
Jerusalem just and we are working on
that documentary by the way we did it we
did a couple more edits yesterday we're
piecing it all together but what was
just so incredible about Jerusalem is
that they are as much as they are
building up meaning that they're
building buildings up always and the
population of Jerusalem is growing
they're also digging down and they're
uncovering history so it's like the
future and the past and they're doing it
at the exact same time and when you
really go and you see how they do these
excavations and they can show you that
as the as you go down and you go down
floors and they build stairs down these
excavate excavation sites and you go
down and you see and they can tell you
well there's a layer of Ash here and
that's when the city was destroyed and
they go beneath that and this is this is
from the Byzantine era and this is from
when the Romans conquered and this is
when the Greeks were here and then you
can connect that to biblical stories and
all these things it's just it's just
absolutely incredible and also the city
was unbelievably beautiful and peaceful
you know we did post some clips of
different things and the peaceful the
walking down the streets of Jerusalem
Muslim women in burkas walking by
Orthodox Jews and not stabbing each
other not killing each other it's not to
say it doesn't ever happen but but the
sense of Peace there was was really
incredible uh David says will you be
watching Mission Impossible Barbie or
Oppenheimer this month
first off I'm gonna freak you guys out I
feel like this one's gonna really blow
your mind particularly Connor I have
never seen any of the Mission Impossible
movies
I have never seen any of the mission I
have never seen any of the Mission
Impossible movies and I have never seen
any of the Fast and the Furious
I know that they're very fast
I have never seen any of those movies I
I you know some and I you know what I've
also never seen you're not gonna believe
this one I've never seen any of the
Bourne movies born identity Supremacy
will you give that fit you're out of
here I'm just something you know you
just miss things you just miss things in
life and there's so many of these
freaking things it's like I got a life
to live I can't start these things right
now you know what I mean I got a lot
cooking
um so probably not Mission Impossible
Oppenheimer and what was and the Barbie
no well I'm not going to see Barbie
obviously like I'll see some clips and
like you know if I want to see if I want
to see some like crazy trans lunatic in
the middle of whatever I could just turn
on The View and then uh what was the
other one oh Oppenheimer yeah which
looks absolutely incredible I don't know
that we'll be able to get it's hard for
us to get out and go to the theater
movie theater and all that but is it
coming out that's you told me just in
theaters right it's not coming out
July 21st in theaters probably not in
theaters maybe I could pull it off and
Off the Grid August but if not uh we'll
definitely see that one uh when it's out
on Apple TV uh all right well we did 48
minutes I thought we were going to be a
little abbreviated today because I know
I'm needed downstairs I can only imagine
what's going on on my yeah I got texts
okay I gotta get down there and clean up
some puke
which I've never ended a show like that
before uh I hope you guys have a great
day uh we're gonna do a quick post game
show at reubenreport.locals.com part one
of my interview with RFK is up across
platforms the full thing is up ad free
of course on locals uh we leave you with
a funny little political Compass moment
and we'll see everybody in the post game
in just a sec
now the main problem area is up here all
of this going on up here is what's
causing me the most physical discomfort
it's like a visceral reaction of
discontent coming from this area this
area is not good either I hate this but
I'm mainly worried about this
foreign
[Music]